new protests are planned over the police
killing of an unarmed black man in
Sacramento after prosecutors declined to
charge the officers 22 year old Stephon
Clark was shot and killed last month in
his grandmother's backyard now this case
led to nationwide protests Jamie yuccas
shows us how Clark's family is now
demanding justice
I would like accountability I want
justice and accountability
Steve on take Clark is calling on
California's Attorney General to
intervene after the Sacramento County
District Attorney decided not to charge
the two officers responsible for his
brother's death police fired multiple
shots at 22-year old Stefan Clark in his
grandmother's backyard last March while
responding to reports of vandalism the
coroner says he was hit seven times on
Saturday District Attorney Anne Marie
Schubert announced that the officers had
reason to believe their lives were at
risk
she said Clark seen here in a grainy
image ignored commands he moved toward
the officers who saw this flash of light
they thought was a gun authorities later
discovered it was a cell phone the
decision ignited protests outside the
police department over the weekend and
at the small what we're asking for
clearly is for those two killer police
officers to be fired immediately
investigators determined that Clark had
been smashing car windows while under
the influence of drugs the night of his
death they also revealed he was possibly
suicidal after a domestic violence
incident involving his fiancee still
Clark's family insists those details do
not justify his death Stefan is dreams
being fulfilled not just a kid who died
in his grandmother's backyard for CBS
this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles no thanks to
Jamie